this is a very disturbing story we
learned about this afternoon metro
police arrested a man accused of sex
trafficking a young child this is
Anthony Terry police say a young girl
telling them Terry would dress her up
and send her to the Las Vegas Strip to
solicit sex for money if she did not
make his required dollar amount police
say she'd face very disturbing
consequences tonight Terry is facing
numerous charges the child who is under
14 years old thankfully is safe also if
you know someone who needs your help in
this area call the number on your screen
we'll pop that up in a second it is for
the national human trafficking Resource
Center there it is
1-888-373-7888 you can also call Metro
Police or the FBI at any time